let's start from the beginning because
we have john here yeah to just tell us
the story a lot of people don't know
about what went down with brenda taylor
i'm sure many activists will just accuse
you of lying but at the very least
let's see
if you would like to you know give us
the breakdown of the story i know you
have a book about it but you can just
tell us what happened we'll go from
there yeah i'll give you the
5 000 view story of it so that night um
we were asked to help what can you you
know the date specifically yeah so march
12th is when the briefing was we didn't
breach the door until march 13th which
is friday night full moon
um
i came out from the briefing and i had
two flat tires it started pouring down
rain i got soaking wet while i was
moving my stuff from one car to the
other so everything was just kind of one
of those nights can you what was the
briefing
it was for so we we had a two separate
briefing swat did their briefing because
they were they were executing the warren
stone elliot
um the guys who were assisting them that
were going to do the searches were at
our brief
along with us
all the the
houses that we were doing were on the
board they showed above it fortunately i
took a picture it showed above it
no knock no no no no it got to ours it
said knock and announce
so they had changed it they were all
signed as no knocks so technically we
served a no knock warrant but it was not
served as a no knock
it was signed by judges and no knock but
once it did not fit the parameters of a
no knock we didn't serve it as a no
knock we did the thing we're supposed to
do we corrected it and didn't do it
so the only reason it served it was
written as a no knock is because
jamarcus glover's history he had five i
believe it was five
felony pending cases for guns and drugs
he had ran from the police uh and these
were active cases not including the ones
he'd already been
charged with and and pled guilty to
previously from mississippi and
louisville
and so
once they realized they had a ping on
his on his phone and a tracker on his
car they knew he would not be on
springfield so they said we're not doing
that one as a no knock because it didn't
justify being a no knock he wasn't there
and they set up we think it's only
brianna taylor at the house we don't
think there's any kids no dogs nobody
else there with her okay cool they've
been watching this house for a while so
i had assumed that their
intelligence was good on the house that
it was just going to be brianna taylor
they said she's a heavyset black female
give her time to come to the door give
her more time than usual because
normally it's about 10 seconds you're
banging on the door please search
warrant if you don't hear anything then
you go ahead and hit it so this one we
went we showed up and we gave it 45
seconds to a minute it was i think six
different cadences of knocking on the
door and yelling police search warrant
the first two were just regular knocks
hoping she would just come to the door
be quiet the neighbors wouldn't know
after she didn't come started banging an
open hand really loud yelling police
search warrant the neighbor upstairs
heard us came out
argued with our guys they kept trying to
go inside he didn't want to go back
inside
so finally he did
we hit the door
once the door opened i could see from
right to left in the living room
and i was on the left of the door jamb
and mike the guy who did the rain was on
the right because you never stand in the
fatal funnel in case somebody shoots
through the door
so once the door came over i scanned to
the right to left everybody at this
point yelling please search warrant
please search warrant
when i turned the corner i had to step
right in the doorway just to see down
this hall and as soon as i did there's
an ambient light coming out from the tv
down the hall
we had lights on our guns as soon as i
turned the corner i saw two people
overlapping each other it was like a big
blob but with a tall head and a short
head and they were both down and this
hallway is only
maybe three four feet wide at the most
so very narrow hallway because it had an
inset where kenneth was standing that
goes into the next bedroom and that's
brianna's boyfriend yes it's her
boyfriend this time
and so as soon as my eyes got to kenneth
i never even got all the way to brianna
even though they were like it was
basically one person but i never got to
her face as soon as i got to where
kenneth was i could see the gun because
the flashlight all i saw was the metal
tip of the gun and my brain was like oh
and boom it was over he shot he shot
first yes he shot i felt it hit my leg i
returned fire i got four rounds off yeah
was the first shot fired it hit you yes
so so
you open the door
kenneth what's you know his last name
walker walker fires one round striking
you in the leg right and then the other
officer's returned fire correct i fired
four i got offline is what it's called
so boom boom boom boom real quick four
shots got behind the door frame came
around shot two more at that time i felt
my leg realized there was a ton of blood
and i've seen you know countless gunshot
victims over 21 years and a normal leg
shot that doesn't hit an artery is it
doesn't bleed much i mean you might have
a trickle of blood down your leg that's
it well this one as soon as i put my
hand on my thigh i could feel just a
glob and i was like oh man and i
announced at the door i mean everything
happened so quick so i got six rounds
off in probably less than two seconds i
mean it's how quick this whole exchange
happens it's over before you even
realize what's going on training kicks
in and you just react
so i remember yelling it hit my femoral
artery and i sat down on my bottom
because i thought i can't i'm gonna pump
the blood out that's what i was thinking
in my head
and as i did that miles stepped up and
was shooting already and i thought i
can't stay here i'm gonna get shot by
crossfire so i jump up and i hobble out
and i fall between the cars
and uh my lieutenant comes up and they
start working on me i'm like dude i need
a tourniquet get me a tourniquet
and uh they finally got one got it on
and got the bleeding stopped but at that
time you got people say well why did why
were there so many shots fired
12 seconds in the dark the book the
title comes from the time that door came
open
until it was silent from no gunshots the
chaos stopped and that was about 10 to
12 seconds from what we've tried to
reenact it and see
and
so much happened so much chaos so many
things go through your mind in that 12
seconds
that it's just amazing how much damage
can be done in that small amount of time
and how much aftermath damage the city
the country the nation
from 12 seconds and it's just it's it's
sad so uh so you get out of there you
say you collapsed between two cars about
how what was the difference between
between the door and where you ended up
on the ground
with getting medical attention so i'll
try to give you a visual of it uh if
you're looking at an apartment complex
and they have the the
inside where the stairs go up to the top
you've got that little foyer area which
is maybe i don't know 12 feet deep and
10 feet wide that's where we were at
this is ground ground floor ground floor
and so i was all the way on the inside
so i hobbled out of there then a
sidewalk curb and then the length of a
car so i went down between the cars butt
scooted to the edge of the cars and
that's when my lieutenant grabbed my
vest and pulled me out
and got to work but the thing about
kenneth walker
you know he keeps saying he didn't know
it was the police first the first they
said nobody knocked and announced then
he comes back later and goes yeah we
heard him knocking we heard him banging
and i thought it was her ex-boyfriend is
what he said
um
so if you thought but then he said he
thought somebody was doing a home
invasion if you thought that why would
you have your girlfriend they got up got
dressed he retrieved a gun why would you
tell your girlfriend come in the hall
with me i'd imagine if he thought it was
her boyfriend
you know what i mean like they genuinely
but if you if you're that scared for
your life that you're willing to shoot
wouldn't you have her call 9-1-1
stay in here and call 9-1-1 get them
over here i mean
you know it's a tough question about
whether or not somebody wants to call
the police a situation that's about to
get hot whether they're thinking about
it how someone reacts i mean you know
you're talking about 12 seconds they
hear a big bang it's about 45 seconds
i can't assume these people
would react the same way i would i can't
assume they trust cops
you know to come and resolve the problem
but more importantly i mean it's even
fair to say
they're not going to call the cops
because they might be involved in
illicit dealings or something and so
this is street justice that's probably
more the case so when they downloaded
his phone after the fact they found text
messages in there with him and other
guys you know there's pictures of him
with this gun which no big deal
everybody can have a gun
uh but they had it also with a bag of
like pills that were probably fentanyl
pills because they were the same little
blue pills
weed whatever nobody cares about weed
and
so
but he was selling there's text messages
in there him selling all this stuff to
different people that's irrelevant the
one that that stuck out was the one
where these other guys said hey do you
want to hit this lick with us he said
well how much is it worth they said 20
grand and he was like it's fine but i
always do my homework first meaning he
sets up watches people see how they
react yeah and again this guy didn't
have a job
he was getting ready to start one day it
was ups the next day it was postal i
don't know which one it was but he was
getting ready to start a job that's
always the case
getting ready to get my life together
and
so
a lot of times what these what these
drug dealers will do they'll rob other
drug dealers that's just common practice
they won't report it to the police
because what are you going to say stole
my drugs of money and but the way they
do it is they'll go up and they'll bang
on a door and yell police and when that
door gets open they've got a gun in and
they rob them that happens all the time
you think that's what he thought was
happening i don't know if that was his
mo of previous cases that he had done so
he thought uh oh it's coming back on me
yeah i don't know it's hard to say
because he's lied so many times we don't
know the truth there's the simple uh
uh general circumstance nuance excluded
that i've mentioned in the past that if
you're a a law-abiding citizen armed
legally and someone kicks your door in
and you don't know it's the police you
have a right to defend yourself from
perceived home invasion i agree
absolutely there have been many you know
stories i've seen uh uh read about or a
couple at least where plainclothes cops
you know are serving a no-knock warrant
or something and then they get shot and
the person ends up you know going to
prison or whatever and i'm like dude i
think that's horrible yeah but uh when
you say playing close let me let me
correct this because this was a big
sticking point on ours too because we
were in what's called plain clothes
however we had tactical vests on that
said police across the front yeah uh we
had our badges on
um you know seven white dudes going to a
black guy's house it's just not the norm
that's gonna go rob a drug dealer it's
just not it doesn't happen
um let's let's
go ahead i'll just say let's let's let's
let's move forward with the story a
little bit and talk about the lies so
the big narrative that comes out was
that brianna taylor was sleeping in her
bed and you guys just basically shot
into the house willy-nilly killing her
while she slept yeah the big thing not
true we came in in the middle of the
night didn't knock didn't announce and
killed her in her sleep
so she was sleeping before we got there
but ben crump's the one that kept
pushing this she was asleep in her bed
thing asleep over over over he get he
came out initially and said they even
had the wrong house they weren't even
supposed to be there and i'm going oh my
god we've got the we've got the search
warrant but our city refused to put it
out
they i'm like just show them the address
and name on it it's all you got to do
you know this doesn't hurt the
investigation one bit
do you you mentioned before that uh
they were gentrifying the area yes
something was going on with that what
was that about so down on elliot which
is where glover was at where they where
swat did the no knocks for years they
had been buying up these properties what
they would do is they would go in and
they would condemn them bound from the
homeowners for a buck a piece
and so the city had taken the majority
of that block in 2000 i believe it was
18 they had the university of kentucky's
engineering department or architectural
department draw up plans for this new
revitalized area and it looked nice and
you do want areas like that to be
revitalized but you've got to do it the
right way you can't just go in and bully
people out of their houses and basically
steal it as a government i don't agree
with that so
what they did was they sent a map out
through their through their email and it
had the houses they already had marked
off and it showed the houses they needed
to still get
so in january they started this new unit
up called pbi place-based investigations
they got it from cincinnati
and
what that what this was supposed to do
is go after your most violent or your
most troublesome areas
to clean up those neighborhoods because
even in these poor neighborhoods 80 of
the people are great people they really
are they're just stuck in an area that
they can't get out of
and i think the government resources
could be used so much different to get
these people on their feet and out
for instance and this is off topic of
this but this is just my little rant on
this kind of stuff because when you keep
these people entrapped like this and
enslaved with all the government
assistance and their inability to get
out then it causes these problems to
compound and these guys are looking for
ways out by selling drugs or robbing
people or doing whatever they have to do
to survive i mean it does become
survival of the fittest in some of these
areas if you go in these areas at night
it's like a third world country i mean
you wouldn't believe it and that's the
problem with most of the citizens they
don't live in those areas so they don't
know what it's like when you go after
dark and there's gunshots and there's
fights and there's i mean it's just you
go oh my goodness this wasn't like this
two hours ago you know when the sun was
up it's just different
but i think they could go in and and say
you're on section 8 or assistance
instead of just constantly giving you
money why don't they
or i mean these women get trapped okay
here's your assistance but if you make x
amount of money we're taking that
assistance away
why don't you let them succeed in their
careers
for five years and then slowly taper off
the assistance while they're
achieving this so they can get out of
this environment right i agree i mean
then in the end the government's saving
money because you're not keeping these
people on your payroll for their entire
life and you're helping the community by
getting them out and getting them
established and then 15 20 years from
now when they're having kids and their
kids are having kids you've got a
totally different it's like turning the
pond over every year you know and you
get you get new stuff
but on this case the gentrification he
was
they were they came in
and a guy from uh
the mayor's office came in every single
week and met with this unit and all the
bosses
all the assistant chiefs would come in
and they would come in they would talk
about what they needed to do to secure
the rest of this what were you doing
they were going right on the whiteboard
i was never involved in those meetings
didn't care didn't want to be i had my
own job
but they were there every single week
and when this all came down the mayor
was like well i don't know why they were
there i have no idea and when that came
up the gentrification he was like i
didn't know anything about that
and but his name's on the emails yeah he
knew this was a guy from his office
conducting these meetings his
a woman that he ended up having an
affair with allegedly
was the project manager for this thing
so there's a lot of things that are
going on this sounds like what actually
happened with the story is dirtier and
bigger than people realize i mean when
you mentioned that i'm like this sounds
like there's probably real estate
developers involved who go to the city
and say we want to turn a profit so he
says we're going to clean up this
neighborhood you got it what's funny he
uses a certain friend
i won't say his name but he uses a
certain friend they already redeveloped
one end of the town that was a a real
bad end to town it's called nulu now and
it's they brought in restaurants and and
it's neat you know it's kind of a yuppie
area
but
the same developer got all those bids
all those contracts and he was the one
that was going to get these so there's a
lot of under the table deals going on
and unfortunately the police are always
used as the ponds like we were talking
about earlier with the uh with the
vaccine stuff mandates enforcing that
yep
if i can use the police who have the
authority as my pawns to go do it then i
can look back and go and it wasn't me it
was the cops these cops just need to say
i'm not going to 100 they do yes they do
well let's i want to carry on the story
though so so so here you are now you
wake up in the hospital
uh uh briana taylor has died uh did
kenneth get injured in any way no
so
you you're what happens you pass out on
the ground no i stayed alert conscious
the whole time and i've told people and
i've told people because i've went
around and talked to some people about
critical incidents
and you're not required by law to give a
statement right away because in critical
incidents a lot of people
if you wait a few days some things you
start remembering stuff that you've you
know for your own protection you blocked
out
and
but for some reason when i woke up it
was like it was burned into my brain and
i say i wish i would have at least if i
didn't give my official statement i wish
i would have recorded it that day
because it hadn't changed one bit i mean
everything i said then i said now the
only things i forgot i forgot i'd put a
ball cap on that night because i got
rained on and i'm real conscious about
my hair so i threw a hat on because it
was all all messed up
so i forgot about that but other than
that it was like
it was burned in me so
um but i waited 12 days to give a
statement because i was in the hospital
then recovering on pain meds and all
that and so
that became an issue because they were
like oh it's a cover-up why do you wait
so long to give a statement i'm like oh
my gosh you know yeah this is my
statement it hasn't changed every
interview is the same but um so what did
you ask me on that particularly no just
just what happens next so you you you're
you're injured you stay up all night
you're in the hospital i'm wondering you
know what happens when you realize this
was turning into a national story there
were like
was it riots are starting up or or the
news is picking it up so
one of the first things i asked my wife
i was like man was anybody hurt because
i didn't know i didn't know if anybody'd
been shot in the apartment because you
know i was busy trying to tend to myself
and say stay alive
um
and they told me yeah i was a female and
i was like crap because i knew
when i came there the taller one was
probably a guy i couldn't pick him out
but you know you kind of knew you could
kind of tell body types and i was like
man because every cop's biggest fear is
at least mine i can't speak for
everybody my biggest fear in this career
has always been i don't want to
accidentally shoot or kill the wrong
person i mean that's just a thought that
you're constantly playing because
there's been other times i could have
been involved in shootings where people
pulled guns or i've been shot at another
warrant and didn't return fire because i
couldn't see through what i was shooting
at
and
because the fear is always
i only want to do the right thing i
don't want to overstep these boundaries
and and in this position take somebody's
life because it's it's a pretty heavy
burden yeah and when that happened i was
like oh my goodness because after
ferguson everything every cop shooting
that comes out now
we go
were they black or white you know not
was it a good shooter bad shoe which
should be all that matters color should
not play any relevance to it but it does
so ever since michael brown that's the
question were they black or white well i
knew brown was black because i'd seen
her picture prior to this
and so i was like my goodness you know
this is this isn't going to be good i
just kind of knew it
and
however covet the the nation shut down
on march 13th also that's when
everything shut down president was on
every day our governor was on every day
so
it kind of got pushed down and i think
that's what our mayor and our police
chief
counted on oh okay well if this is the
big story we can just this will go away
something else will come up
and then a mod aubry happened
and ben crump was hired on a mod aubry
well then
after that one of the attorneys on
briana taylor's case for her mother
knew ben crump she had worked with him
on a case
so she called him and said hey can you
help us on this one so he came into town
and then
things had already been there had
already been lies or misconceptions and
part of that was the police department's
fault because they didn't share any
information with brianna taylor's family
either so i understand their frustration
i get it
um
but then once he got on it was a whole
new animal man it was because he already
had the national spotlight from ahmad
aubry so then now brianna taylor's there
and so i could feel
the tension in the city starting to
creep up you could feel it and i started
reaching out to people i even reached
out to our uh city council president who
used to be a police officer he was my
training officer in the academy
and i said man i texted him i've still
got it on my phone i was like here's all
the lies they're saying and i listed it
as pages of text and i said here's what
really happened and i told exactly what
i've told you guys
and i said the mayor won't say it what
can we do and he said yeah the mayor's
refusing to say this stuff i'll hold a
press conference monday and get it out
never happened thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there